Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 9.32pm on Friday, March 18, 1994, a call came through to the South Australian Ambulance Service helpline. On the other line was a distressed male. My fiance has had an accident in the bath, he said.
我们的剧集涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上的本集节目说明。1994年3月18日星期五晚上9点32分，南澳大利亚救护车服务热线接到一个电话。电话那头是一名痛苦的男子。他说，我的未婚妻在浴缸里出了事故。
I think she has drowned. The operator began asking questions, but the caller was in a state of panic. He put the phone down, explaining he was performing CPR. Six minutes later, two paramedics arrived at a federation-styled duplex in McGill, a leafy suburb seven kilometres east of Adelaide CBD. The house belonged to 29-year-old lawyer Anna Jane Cheney. She lived there with her fiance, 39-year-old financial adviser Henry Keough, who was the one who placed the call.
我想她溺水了。接线员开始询问，但打电话的人处于恐慌状态。他放下电话，解释说他正在进行心肺复苏。六分钟后，两名医护人员抵达了位于阿德莱德中央商务区以东七公里处绿树成荫的麦吉尔区的一栋联邦风格复式住宅。这所房子属于29岁的律师安娜·简·切尼。她与未婚夫、39岁的财务顾问亨利·基奥住在一起，正是他拨打了那个电话。
A distraught Henry hurried the paramedics into the small L-shaped bathroom located at the front of the house. Anna Jane was lying on the floor naked, her body halfway between the bathroom and the adjoining bedroom. Her skin was visibly pale, and her dark blonde hair was wet against the bedroom carpet. Henry dropped to his knees and hunched over Anna Jane's body, weeping. The paramedics asked him to move aside as they commenced resuscitation. Straight away, they noticed a significant blockage in her airway.
心烦意乱的亨利催促医护人员进入位于房子前部的小型L型浴室。安娜·简赤身裸体地躺在地板上，身体处于浴室和相邻卧室之间。她的皮肤明显苍白，深金色的头发湿漉漉地贴在卧室的地毯上。亨利跪倒在地，弓着身子伏在安娜·简的尸体上哭泣。医护人员要求他让开，随即开始抢救。他们立刻注意到她的气道有严重的阻塞。
They tried to unblock it, but it was no use. Anna Jane was already dead. Given it was an unexplained and sudden death, police were summoned to the scene to rule out foul play. When officers arrived, they found Henry crying next to Anna Jane's lifeless body, his head resting on her chest. Henry Keough told officers that after knocking off work on Friday, March 18, he and Anna Jane met at a trendy suburban pub to unwind.
他们试图清理阻塞物，但无济于事。安娜·简已经死亡。鉴于这是一起无法解释的猝死，警方被传唤到现场以排除他杀可能。当警察到达时，他们发现亨利在安娜·简毫无生气的尸体旁哭泣，头靠在她的胸口。亨利·基奥告诉警察，3月18日星期五下班后，他和安娜·简在一家时髦的郊区酒吧见面放松。
They chatted over several glasses of Chardonnay and a bowl of potato wedges before heading home. They weren't there long before Anna Jane had to leave to meet her sister-in-law Sue, who was also her best friend. The two had arranged to walk their dogs in a nearby park while discussing the latest wedding plans. In just six weeks' time, Anna Jane and Henry were due to get married, with Sue serving as bridesmaid.
他们喝了几杯霞多丽葡萄酒，吃了一碗薯角，聊了一会儿才回家。他们没待多久，安娜·简就不得不离开去见她的小姑子苏，苏也是她最好的朋友。两人约定在附近的公园遛狗，同时讨论最新的婚礼计划。再过六个星期，安娜·简和亨利就要结婚了，苏将担任伴娘。
Anna Jane jumped into her Volvo with her energetic bearded collie, Jordan. Her catch-up with Sue was short, yet enjoyable. At around 8pm, the sisters farewell one another, making plans to see each other again the following weekend. Anna Jane drove back towards her home, looking forward to a quiet night in. At home, Anna Jane encouraged Henry to go see his mother. Henry and his mum had a somewhat tumultuous relationship, and it had been about six weeks since he had last paid her a visit.
安娜·简带着她精力充沛的胡须牧羊犬乔丹跳进了她的沃尔沃汽车。她与苏的会面很短暂，但很愉快。晚上8点左右，姐妹俩道别，并计划下周末再见。安娜·简开车回家，期待着一个安静的夜晚。回到家，安娜·简鼓励亨利去看看他的母亲。亨利和他的母亲关系有些动荡，他已经有大约六个星期没去看望她了。
They agreed that it was a good idea. His mother only lived five minutes away, so it wouldn't take long. Meanwhile, Anna Jane was tired and her back was sore. She told Henry she'd soak in a bath while he was gone. Henry left at around 8.20pm, arriving at his mother's house shortly after. He stayed for about 45 minutes before returning home. It was roughly 9.30pm by the time he pulled into the duplex driveway. Anna Jane's Volvo was right where she'd left it, and her dog Jordan rushed to the front
他们一致认为这是个好主意。他母亲住的地方只有五分钟路程，所以不会花太长时间。与此同时，安娜·简很累，背部酸痛。她告诉亨利，趁他不在，她会泡个澡。亨利在晚上8点20分左右离开，不久后到达他母亲家。他待了大约45分钟后回家。当他把车开进复式住宅的车道时，大约是晚上9点30分。安娜·简的沃尔沃还在她离开的地方，她的狗乔丹冲向了前门。
door. But when Henry entered the house, it was oddly silent. He called out, but there was no response. He walked down the hall, only to find the kitchen and lounge room empty. He went back down the hall, then paused. He could tell the light was on in the bathroom, but nothing stirred within. He gave the door a push. Inside, Anna Jane was slumped over in the tub, lying on her right hand side facing north.
但当亨利进入房子时，里面异常安静。他大声呼喊，但没有回应。他沿着走廊走去，发现厨房和客厅空无一人。他回到走廊，停了下来。他能看出浴室里亮着灯，但里面没有任何动静。他推开了门。里面，安娜·简瘫倒在浴缸里，右侧卧着，面朝北。
Her nose and mouth were completely submerged in the water, her skin pale and eyes glassy. Henry tried to lift Anna Jane out of the bath, but this proved difficult on account of him having an injured back. The water was also making everything slippery. Instead, Henry tried to let the water out of the bath, but Anna Jane's body was blocking the plug. He managed to maneuver his hands under Anna Jane's arms. Hugging her tight to his chest, Henry then dragged her wet body out of the tub, where
她的鼻子和嘴完全浸在水里，皮肤苍白，眼睛呆滞。亨利试图把安娜·简从浴缸里抬出来，但由于他背部有伤，这很困难。水也让一切变得湿滑。亨利转而试图放掉浴缸里的水，但安娜·简的身体堵住了排水塞。他设法把手伸到安娜·简的腋下。亨利紧紧地抱着她，把她湿漉漉的身体从浴缸里拖了出来，然后
it flopped onto the floor. Henry had volunteered with the ambulance service 15 years prior, and he tried to remember his CPR training. He felt Anna Jane's throat, but his own heart was racing so fast that he couldn't tell if she still had a pulse. He checked her airway before commencing mouth-to-mouth resuscitation and chest compressions. When he's panic, he couldn't remember if the number for emergency services was triple zero or triple one.
她瘫倒在地板上。亨利15年前曾在救护车服务中心做过志愿者，他试图回忆心肺复苏的训练。他摸了摸安娜·简的喉咙，但自己的心跳太快，无法判断她是否还有脉搏。他在开始口对口人工呼吸和胸外按压前检查了她的气道。由于惊慌，他不记得紧急服务电话是000还是111。
Instead, he called the direct ambulance helpline while continuing to administer CPR. At no time did Anna Jane move or make a sound. The responding police officers examined the scene. The tub that ran along the back wall of the bathroom was three-quarters full of tepid water and there was no blood or vomit to be seen. It didn't look like Anna Jane had fallen and hurt herself or suffered a sudden illness. There were no signs of forced entry or any kind of violence or struggle. Police therefore concluded it was a non-suspicious death.
相反，他拨打了救护车直接热线，同时继续进行心肺复苏。安娜·简始终没有动弹，也没有发出任何声音。赶到的警察检查了现场。沿着浴室后墙的浴缸里装了四分之三的温水，没有看到血迹或呕吐物。看起来安娜·简并没有摔倒受伤或突发疾病。没有强行闯入的迹象，也没有任何暴力或挣扎的痕迹。因此，警方断定这是一起非可疑死亡。
Anna Jane had likely fallen asleep or passed out in the tub and drowned. Henry notified the Cheney family of Anna Jane's death. For them, things didn't make sense. Anna Jane was a healthy young woman with no medical history that would explain a sudden loss of consciousness. She had consumed four glasses of wine at the pub with Henry that night, yet her sister in law Sue didn't think she'd seemed affected by alcohol when they met at the park to walk their dogs.
安娜·简很可能是在浴缸里睡着或昏迷后溺水的。亨利通知了切尼一家安娜·简的死讯。对他们来说，这一切都说不通。安娜·简是一个健康的年轻女性，没有任何病史可以解释这种突然的意识丧失。那天晚上她在酒吧和亨利喝了四杯酒，但她的小姑子苏在公园遛狗时并不觉得她受到了酒精的影响。
Anna Jane wasn't a drug user and was otherwise looking forward to the future. She had recently secured a senior position with the Law Society of South Australia, an impressive achievement for someone of her age and experience. It was a demanding role, but one that Anna Jane thrived in. Colleagues admired her ability to blend her ambitious and career-focused dedication with her characteristic warmth and joy. They did recall that Friday had been a particularly stressful day at Anna Jane's work, but no one she interacted with that day noted anything out of the ordinary.
安娜·简不吸毒，而且对未来充满期待。她最近在南澳大利亚法律协会获得了一个高级职位，对于她这个年龄和经验的人来说，这是一项令人印象深刻的成就。这是一个要求很高的角色，但安娜·简在其中游刃有余。同事们钦佩她将雄心勃勃的职业专注力与她特有的热情和快乐融合在一起的能力。他们确实记得那个星期五是安娜·简工作中特别忙碌的一天，但那天与她接触的人都没有注意到任何异常。
When a deceased body is found in water, there is nothing in an autopsy that will exclusively prove that the individual died from drowning. Therefore, a range of factors such as injury, heart attack, stroke and severe allergic reaction need to be ruled out before drowning can be concluded as the cause of death. The task of conducting Anna Jane Cheney's autopsy was assigned to Dr Colin Mannock, the senior director of forensic pathology at South Australia's Forensic Science Centre. He'd conducted around 9,000 autopsies over the span of his 30-year career and was considered by many to be the state's top forensic expert.
当在水中发现尸体时，尸检中没有任何证据能专门证明死者死于溺水。因此，在得出溺水是死因的结论之前，需要排除受伤、心脏病发作、中风和严重过敏反应等一系列因素。进行安娜·简·切尼尸检的任务被分配给了南澳大利亚法医科学中心法医病理学高级主任科林·曼诺克博士。他在30年的职业生涯中进行了大约9000次尸检，被许多人认为是该州顶尖的法医专家。
Dr Mannock couldn't find any trauma that would have rendered Anna Jane unconscious, but he did notice a 3-centimeter circular bruise on the top of her forehead, which appeared to have occurred shortly before she died. There was also a small bruise on the back of her neck. Blood and tissue samples were taken from her lungs, heart and brain for further testing and to exclude any significant medical conditions. Until then, Dr Mannock reported his findings to the coroner, determining the provisional cause of death to be freshwater drowning.
曼诺克博士没有发现任何会导致安娜·简昏迷的创伤，但他确实注意到她前额上方有一个3厘米的圆形淤青，这似乎是在她死前不久发生的。她的后颈部也有一个小淤青。从她的肺部、心脏和大脑中提取了血液和组织样本进行进一步检测，以排除任何重大的医疗状况。在此之前，曼诺克博士向验尸官报告了他的发现，将初步死因定为淡水溺水。
He said no further reports would be necessary unless the tests revealed something of note. But the bruising concerned him. It was an unusual position that didn't look like it could have been caused by a fall. A constable who worked for the coronial investigation section had attended Anna Jane's home on the night she died. From the get-go, she'd felt that there was something a little off about the whole situation. She found Henry Keough's behaviour at the scene to be odd, describing his display of grief as, quote, crocodile tears.
他说，除非检测结果显示出值得注意的情况，否则不需要进一步的报告。但淤青让他感到担忧。这是一个不寻常的位置，看起来不像是摔倒造成的。一名在验尸调查部门工作的警官在安娜·简去世当晚曾到过她的家。从一开始，她就觉得整个情况有点不对劲。她发现亨利·基奥在现场的行为很奇怪，形容他的悲伤表现为“鳄鱼的眼泪”。
Upon reading the report, she noted that the location of the bruise at the top of Anna Jane's head didn't fit with her falling face first or with her head back. The constable requested further inquiries be conducted to explain how the bruise occurred, and she wasn't the only one who had questions. There was no doubt in anyone's mind that Anna Jane was deeply in love with Henry Keough. The two had met at a popular city pub in 1989. At the time, Henry was working for the now defunct state bank. He'd previously pursued careers in dentistry and sales before finding his calling in the
在阅读报告时，她注意到安娜·简头顶淤青的位置与她脸朝下或头向后仰摔倒的情况不符。该警官要求进行进一步调查以解释淤青是如何产生的，而且她并不是唯一有疑问的人。毫无疑问，安娜·简深爱着亨利·基奥。两人于1989年在一家受欢迎的城市酒吧相识。当时，亨利在现已倒闭的州立银行工作。在找到自己的职业方向之前，他曾从事牙科和销售工作。
financial industry. Although he didn't have the same upper-class background as Anna Jane and her friends, the two connected on an intellectual level. They began meeting up regularly, and an emotional connection started to grow. Anna Jane was drawn to Henry's quiet intellect and cheery exterior. He enjoyed Anna Jane's quick wit, confidence, and her no-nonsense approach to life. Henry also saw Anna Jane as physically stunning. Within weeks, they'd formed a romantic relationship.
尽管他没有像安娜·简和她的朋友们那样的上流社会背景，但两人在智力层面上产生了共鸣。他们开始定期见面，情感联系开始增长。安娜·简被亨利安静的才智和开朗的外表所吸引。他喜欢安娜·简的机智、自信和务实的生活态度。亨利也认为安娜·简外表迷人。几周之内，他们就建立了恋爱关系。
To outsiders, Anna Jane was smitten. But for the rest of the Cheney family, the feeling wasn't mutual. While they tolerated Henry on a social level, they simply didn't feel he was right for Anna Jane. In addition to the 10-year age gap between them, there was something about Henry they didn't trust. After working in various roles over the years, he'd recently started a new job in a stockbroking firm.
在外人看来，安娜·简被迷住了。但对于切尼家族的其他成员来说，这种感觉并非相互的。虽然他们在社交层面上容忍亨利，但他们就是觉得他不适合安娜·简。除了他们之间10岁的年龄差距外，亨利身上还有一些他们不信任的地方。在多年从事各种工作后，他最近在一家股票经纪公司找到了一份新工作。
Not only did the Cheneys feel Henry was possessive and somewhat cagey about what he did for a living, he had been married with three children when he started an affair with Anna Jane. Although Henry had since divorced his first wife, he was still financially supporting her and their children. Anna Jane's family wondered about how this might impact their upcoming marriage. Furthermore, since having his third daughter, Henry had had a vasectomy. Although Anna Jane insisted motherhood wasn't high on her list of priorities, there were concerns she might change her mind in the future.
切尼一家不仅觉得亨利占有欲强，而且对自己的职业守口如瓶，而且他在开始与安娜·简有染时已经结婚并有三个孩子。尽管亨利后来与第一任妻子离婚，但他仍在经济上支持她和他们的孩子。安娜·简的家人想知道这可能会如何影响他们即将到来的婚姻。此外，自从有了第三个女儿后，亨利做了输精管结扎手术。尽管安娜·简坚持认为为人母不是她的首要任务，但人们担心她将来可能会改变主意。
When Anna Jane borrowed money from her father to purchase her McGill home in May of 1992, it was on the condition that Henry didn't move in. The pair had been running hot and cold, and the Cheneys suspected that Henry might still be romantically involved with his ex-wife. Anna Jane's mother had once spotted Henry's car in his ex-wife's driveway at a time he told Anna Jane he was interstate. But after some ups and downs, Anna Jane assured her parents that her relationship with Henry was solid.
当安娜·简在1992年5月向父亲借钱购买麦吉尔的房子时，条件是亨利不能搬进去。两人关系时好时坏，切尼一家怀疑亨利可能仍与前妻有染。安娜·简的母亲曾有一次在亨利告诉安娜·简他去外州时，在亨利前妻的车道上看到了亨利的车。但在经历了一些起伏之后，安娜·简向父母保证她与亨利的关系很稳固。
Every month after she purchased her home, Henry was living there full-time. Once the reality of Anna Jane's death began to sink in, her father was eager to make sure her financial affairs were in order. On Sunday, March 20, he asked Henry whether Anna Jane had any insurance policies. Henry responded, No, not that I know of. But as the Cheneys quickly found out, this wasn't the case. The previous July, Henry and Anna Jane had gone on a holiday to Hong Kong.
在她买房后的每个月，亨利都全职住在那里。当安娜·简去世的现实开始显现时，她的父亲急于确保她的财务状况井然有序。3月20日星期日，他问亨利安娜·简是否有任何保险单。亨利回答说：“没有，据我所知没有。”但正如切尼一家很快发现的那样，事实并非如此。前一年7月，亨利和安娜·简去香港度假。
In preparation, Anna Jane had taken out a $400,000 life insurance policy. She told her brother and other friends about it before she left, saying that if anything happened to her, the insurance would settle her $30,000 debt to her father and pay off her mortgage. The rest would go to Henry. This information from the Cheneys, coupled with the questionable bruising on Anna Jane's head, prompted police to investigate her death further. Anna Jane's sister-in-law hadn't noticed the bruise when the pair walked their dogs,
为了准备这次旅行，安娜·简购买了一份40万美元的人寿保险。她在离开前告诉了她的兄弟和其他朋友，说如果她发生什么事，保险将结清她欠父亲的3万美元债务并还清她的抵押贷款。剩下的钱将归亨利所有。切尼一家提供的这些信息，加上安娜·简头上可疑的淤青，促使警方进一步调查她的死因。安娜·简的小姑子在两人遛狗时并没有注意到淤青，
nor had a friend who met with her for lunch on the day she died. However, the dislike for Henry Keough was shared by a majority of Anna Jane's close friends, who deemed him to be secretive and a liar. A former colleague of Henry's also described him as a snake oil salesman. The general consensus was that there was something suspicious about Anna Jane's sudden death. These suspicions were shared by Dr Colin Manock, who had since conducted a second autopsy of Anna Jane's body. Two days after she passed, Dr Manock noticed what appeared to be three small circular bruises
那天和她共进午餐的朋友也没有注意到。然而，安娜·简的大多数亲密朋友都讨厌亨利·基奥，认为他是个骗子，守口如瓶。亨利的一位前同事也形容他是一个“卖蛇油的推销员”。普遍的共识是，安娜·简的猝死有些可疑。这些怀疑得到了科林·曼诺克博士的认同，他此后对安娜·简的尸体进行了第二次尸检。在她去世两天后，曼诺克博士注意到她左脚踝上方出现了三个小的圆形淤青，左腿内侧也有一个相邻的淤青。随着时间的推移，淤青变得越来越深。曼诺克博士把手放在安娜·简的腿上，意识到他的三根手指和拇指与淤青对齐了。他恍然大悟。这不仅仅是一个随机的图案。这是一个手印。曼诺克博士知道20世纪初发生在英国的一起臭名昭著的案件。
developing just above her left ankle, with an adjacent bruise on the inner left leg. As the days went by, the bruises got darker and darker. Dr Manock placed his hand against Anna Jane's leg, and realized that his three fingers and thumb lined up with the bruises. It dawned on him. This wasn't just a random pattern. It was a handprint. Dr Manock was aware of an infamous case that had occurred in England in the early 20th
在三年时间里，三名身体健康的年轻女性在小浴缸里溺水身亡。一位法医病理学家意识到这三名女性的手肘周围都有类似的淤青。他断定她们根本不是死于意外。有人很可能拉着每个女人的腿，导致她们的上半身滑入水中。水突然涌入她们的鼻腔会迅速使她们失去知觉，
century. Over a period of three years, three otherwise healthy young women had drowned in small bathtubs. A forensic pathologist realized that all three women shared similar bruising around their elbows. He concluded they hadn't died by accident at all. Someone had likely pulled each woman up by their legs, causing their upper bodies to slide under water. The sudden rush of water into their noses would have quickly rendered them unconscious,
然后凶手将她们按在水下直到溺亡。在她们去世时，这三名女性都嫁给了同一个男人，乔治·约瑟夫·史密斯。史密斯与每个女人的联系都没有被注意到，因为他经常改名并搬迁。经确定，他杀死了他的三任妻子以继承她们的钱财。这起案件被称为“浴缸里的新娘谋杀案”。对于曼诺克博士来说，“浴缸里的新娘”案与安娜·简·切尼神秘死亡之间的相似之处不容忽视。
with their killer then holding them under water until they drowned. At the time of their deaths, all three women had been married to the same man, George Joseph Smith. Smith's connection to each woman had gone unnoticed as he changed his name and relocated often. It was determined that he had killed his three wives to inherit their money. The case came to be known as the Brides in the Bath Murders. For Dr Manock, the similarities between the Brides in the Bath case and the mysterious
3月22日星期二，即安娜·简去世四天后，警方带走亨利·基奥进行审讯。在四个半小时的时间里，他们询问了他与安娜·简的关系以及导致她死亡的事件。亨利最初告诉警方，周五晚上他离开家时，安娜·简正在拿食物喂狗。这一次，他说她正在放洗澡水。
death of Anna Jane Cheney couldn't be ignored. On Tuesday, March 22, four days after Anna Jane's death, police took Henry Keough in for questioning. Over four and a half hours, they asked him about his relationship with Anna Jane and the events leading up to her death. Henry had initially told police that when he left his house on Friday night, Anna Jane had been getting food out to feed her dog. This time, he said she was running the bath.
他早些时候说他回家时检查了卧室。这一次，他说他从来没有进过卧室。还有其他不一致之处。在第一份声明中，亨利说他发现安娜·简右侧卧着。但他告诉安娜·简的母亲，他发现她仰卧着。警方询问了亨利的前妻苏珊。她说亨利与安娜·简的婚外情并不是他在婚姻期间第一次不忠。
He'd earlier said that when he came home, he checked the bedroom. This time, he said he never went into the bedroom. There were other inconsistencies too. In his first statement, Henry said he found Anna Jane lying on her right hand side. But he told Anna Jane's mother that he found her lying on her back. Police questioned Henry's ex-wife, Susan. She said Henry's affair with Anna Jane wasn't the first time he'd been unfaithful during their marriage.
无论如何，她深深地关心他，并希望他有一天能回到这个家庭。苏珊告诉警方，两人保持着友谊，但自第一次分居以来就没有发生过性关系。亨利也没有在她的家里过夜。当警方提到亨利与安娜·简订婚时，苏珊感到震惊。这是她第一次听说这件事。对于调查人员来说，这提出了一个问题。如果两人仍然是好朋友，为什么亨利要隐瞒这个信息？
Regardless, she cared about him deeply and hoped he'd one day return to the family. Susan told police the two had maintained a friendship but hadn't been sexual since they first separated. Nor had Henry spent the night at her home since. When the police mentioned Henry's engagement to Anna Jane, Susan was shocked. This was the first she'd heard about it. For investigators, this raised the question. If the two were still close friends, why had Henry kept this information a secret?
难道是因为他根本没打算让婚礼举行？警方拜访了亨利仍居住的麦吉尔住宅，并索要安娜·简的财务记录。当被问及谁是安娜·简遗嘱的受益人时，亨利回答说：“我不知道。”记录显示了不同的情况。亨利被列为遗嘱执行人和主要受益人。除了安娜·简欠她父亲的3万美元购房定金外，她遗产的其余部分都归亨利所有。
Could it be because he never intended for the wedding to go ahead at all? Police visited Henry at the McGill home where he was still living and asked for Anna Jane's financial records. When asked who the beneficiary of Anna Jane's will was, Henry responded, I don't know. The records told a different story. Henry was listed as both the executor and main beneficiary. Other than the $30,000 Anna Jane owed her father for the house deposit. The rest of her estate was to go to Henry.
她在海外度假前购买的40万美元人寿保险只是冰山一角。事实上，安娜·简总共有五份来自不同提供商的人寿保险单，所有这些都是在1993年2月至4月之间购买的，就在她去世前一年多一点。这些保单的总价值为112.5万美元。3月23日星期三，警方回到麦吉尔的房产，通知亨利他们发现他的陈述中存在一些差异。
The $400,000 life insurance policy she'd taken out prior to their overseas holiday was only the tip of the iceberg. In fact, Anna Jane had a total of five life insurance policies with different providers, all of which had been taken out between February and April of 1993, just over a year before her death. In total, the policies were worth $1.125 million. On Wednesday, March 23, police returned to the McGill property and advised Henry they'd picked up on some discrepancies in his statements.
他们知道他在安娜·简的遗嘱和保险单上撒了谎，现在有理由相信她的死是可疑的。他们直截了当地向亨利提出了他们的理论。他们认为，亨利在周五晚上下班后邀请安娜·简去酒吧，目的是让她喝醉。她与小姑子遛狗的计划打乱了他的如意算盘。相反，他一直等到从他母亲家回来。他母亲证实她儿子周五晚上去过，大约在晚上9点20分离开。
They knew he lied about Anna Jane's will and insurance policies, and now had reason to believe that her death was suspicious. They put their theory to Henry bluntly. They believed that Henry had invited Anna Jane out to the pub after finishing work on Friday night with the intention of getting her drunk. Her plans to walk the dogs with her sister-in-law had thrown an unexpected spanner in the works. Instead, he'd waited until he returned from his mother's house. His mother confirmed her son had visited on Friday night, leaving around 9.20pm.
开车回安娜·简家需要五分钟。亨利拨打救护车服务的电话是在晚上9点32分。虽然无法确定确切的死亡时间，但如果安娜·简在亨利到家时已经在浴缸里，这给了他不到10分钟的时间抓住她的脚踝，把她的腿抬过头顶，强行把她的头按在水下直到她失去知觉。现场的一些急救人员觉得亨利确实很痛苦。这可能是悲伤的证据，但也可能是对他刚刚所作所为的反应。
It was a five-minute drive back to Anna Jane's house. Henry's call to the ambulance service was placed at 9.32pm. Although an exact time of death couldn't be established, if Anna Jane was already in the bath when Henry arrived home, this gave him just under 10 minutes to grab her by the ankles and lift her legs up over her head, forcing her head under water until she lost consciousness. Some of the first responders at the scene felt that Henry was genuinely distressed. It was possible this was an evidence of grief but a reaction to what he'd just done.
警方告诉亨利，他是唯一有动机希望安娜·简死的人。由于没有闯入或性侵犯的迹象，一切都指向他。亨利大吃一惊。他拒绝了警方的理论，称是安娜·简周五晚上邀请他去喝酒，而不是相反。他陈述中的任何差异都可以用严重的睡眠不足和当时的情况压力来解释。亨利勉强允许警方搜查房子。
The police told Henry that he was the only one with any motive to want Anna Jane dead. With no signs of a break-in or sexual assault, everything pointed towards him. Henry was taken aback. He rejected the police theory, saying it was Anna Jane who had invited him for drinks on Friday night, not the other way around. Any discrepancies in his statements were explained by a severe lack of sleep and the stress of the situation. Henry reluctantly permitted police to search the house.
他们仔细检查了是否有任何强行闯入或物品丢失的迹象，以排除其他人可能闯入并犯罪的可能性。没有发现任何迹象，邻居们也不记得听到任何叫喊声或可疑的噪音。在安娜·简·切尼去世的那天晚上，大约有12人进入了她的浴室。这包括医护人员、警察、朋友和家人。没有收集到任何法医样本，浴缸里的水在没有进行任何测试的情况下被迅速排干。没有任何措施来保护犯罪现场的完整性。
They double-checked for any signs of forced entry or missing goods to rule out the possibility that someone else could have broken in and committed the crime. There were none, nor did the neighbors recall hearing any shouting or suspicious noises. On the night Anna Jane Cheney died, around 12 people had entered her bathroom. This included paramedics, police, friends and family. No forensic samples had been collected and the bathwater had been promptly drained without any tests being conducted. Nothing had been done to protect the integrity of the crime scene.
事实上，那天晚上每个人离开后，亨利自己独自留在家里，打扫和吸尘。当认为有必要进行法医搜查时，却未能发现任何值得注意的东西。无论如何，3月25日星期五，即安娜·简去世一周后，她的死亡被正式宣布为重大犯罪。她的尸体在同一天移交给了她的家人。3月30日星期三，安娜·简穿着她一直很兴奋地穿着走过红毯的婚纱准备了葬礼。
In fact, Henry himself had stayed home alone after everyone left that night, cleaning and vacuuming the house. By the time it was deemed necessary, a forensic search failed to uncover anything of note. Regardless, on Friday, March 25, one week after Anna Jane had passed away, her death was officially declared a major crime. Her body was released to her family that same day. On Wednesday, March 30, Anna Jane was prepared for her funeral wearing the wedding dress she'd been so excited to wear down the aisle.
人们记得她是将这么多生命编织在一起的银线。当地报纸立即开始报道此案，毫不掩饰警方现在将安娜·简的死视为谋杀。她的母亲恳求任何有信息的人站出来，说她担心其他年轻女性也可能面临风险。当贝琳达·莫里斯（化名）读到新闻时，她给重大犯罪部门发了一份传真，说她有他们可能感兴趣的信息。亨利曾告诉警方他对安娜·简很忠诚，但据贝琳达说，这
She was remembered as the silver thread that wove so many lives together. Local newspapers immediately began reporting on the case, making it no secret that police were now treating Anna Jane's death as a murder. Her mother made a heartfelt plea for anyone with information to come forward, saying she was worried that other young women could also be at risk. When Belinda Morris, not her real name, read the news, she sent a fax through to the major crimes unit saying she had information that might be of interest. Henry had told police he'd been faithful to Anna Jane, but according to Belinda, this
只是这一长串谎言中的又一个。贝琳达在1991年底认识了亨利·基奥，当时他们都在州立银行的不同分行工作。尽管当时他与安娜·简有恋爱关系，但他从未向贝琳达提及此事。相反，他约她出去，两人开始在职业和个人层面上断断续续地见面。亨利甚至在与安娜·简在香港度假时给贝琳达打过电话，尽管
was just another in a long series of lies. Belinda had met Henry Keough in late 1991 when they were both employed in separate branches of the state bank. Although he was in a relationship with Anna Jane at the time, at no point did he mention this to Belinda. Instead, he asked her on a date, and the two began seeing each other on and off in both a professional and personal capacity. Henry had even called Belinda while he was holidaying in Hong Kong with Anna Jane, although
他告诉她他是和一个男性朋友一起旅行。据称，两人在1993年中期发生了身体接触，但直到那年12月才发生性关系。贝琳达自作主张为她和亨利预订了浪漫之旅，但每次他都以不同的借口在最后一刻退缩。1994年1月，安娜·简的名字第一次在工作中被提及。当贝琳达问亨利她是谁时，他显然回答说：“一个前女友。”
he told her he was travelling with a male friend. Things allegedly became physical between the two in mid-1993, but they didn't consummate their relationship until December that year. Belinda took it upon herself to book romantic trips for her and Henry, but each time he bailed at the last minute with a different excuse. It was in January of 1994 that Anna Jane's name came up at work for the first time. When Belinda asked Henry who she was, he apparently responded, An ex-girlfriend.
“她总是给我打电话。她对我着迷。她确信她想嫁给我，但我永远不会娶她。”在1994年的情人节，也就是安娜·简去世前一个月，亨利给了贝琳达一朵玫瑰和一张卡片。贝琳达问这是否意味着亨利完全属于她。据称他回答说：“是的，我是你的，你完全属于我。”
She phones me all the time. She's obsessed with me. She is convinced she wants to marry me, but I will never marry her. And on Valentine's Day in 1994, just one month before Anna Jane died, Henry gave Belinda a rose and a card. Belinda asked if this meant that Henry was all hers. He allegedly responded, Yes, I'm yours, and you're all mine.
贝琳达并不是唯一一个声称在与安娜·简交往期间与亨利有染的人。莫妮卡·科尔曼（化名）于1991年通过工作认识了亨利。他们的关系从职业转向个人，两人开始在社交场合见面。1992年3月，明显心烦意乱的亨利告诉莫妮卡，他需要和他的女朋友安娜分手。他爱她，但她想结婚生子，而这正是亨利最不想做的事情。
Belinda wasn't the only one who claimed to have been romantically involved with Henry during his relationship with Anna Jane. Monica Coleman, not her real name, met Henry through work in 1991. Their relationship went from professional to personal, and the two began meeting up socially. In March 1992, a visibly upset Henry told Monica that he needed to break up with his girlfriend, Anna. He loved her, but she wanted to get married and have children, which was the last thing
亨利断定他会试图通过“让他人逐渐疏远”来温和地结束这段关系。三个月后，莫妮卡和朋友们逛街时遇到了亨利和安娜·简。第二天，亨利打电话给莫妮卡澄清说他们现在只是朋友。从那时起，莫妮卡和亨利进入了她所描述的激烈的性关系。
on Henry's mind. Henry concluded he would try to end things kindly by, quote, weaning Anna Jane off of him. Three months later, Monica was out shopping with friends when she ran into Henry and Anna Jane. The following day, Henry called Monica to clarify that the two of them were now just friends. From there, Monica and Henry entered what she described as an intense sexual relationship.
他们会一起出去吃饭，每周发生多达六次性关系。莫妮卡认为他们是一对，但亨利行为的某些方面让她感到困扰。他不会告诉她他确切住在哪里，但他从不在莫妮卡家待到凌晨2点以后。他总是找借口说他为什么必须离开，并会因为必须看望他的孩子而推掉社交活动。他说他不想做出任何承诺，因为他还在从与安娜·简的分手中恢复过来。
They would dine out together and have sex up to six times a week. Monica considered them to be a couple, but certain things about Henry's behavior bothered her. He wouldn't tell her exactly where he lived, yet he'd never stay at Monica's house later than 2 a.m. He always made excuses as to why he had to leave, and would bail on social events on account of having to see his children. He said he didn't want to make any commitments because he was still getting over his break
莫妮卡最终在1992年12月结束了与亨利的关系。他们继续偶尔见面，但没有进一步的性接触。亨利给人一种他仍然单身的印象，并告诉莫妮卡自他们分手以来他没有与任何人亲密过。莫妮卡不知道的是，此时他已经与安娜·简订婚了。莫妮卡在1994年的情人节与亨利共进午餐，期间他声称自己没有和任何人交往。
up with Anna Jane. Monica eventually ended things with Henry in December of 1992. They continued meeting up every now and then, but had no further sexual contact. Henry gave the impression he was still single and told Monica that he hadn't been intimate with anyone else since their break up. Unbeknownst to Monica, at this point he was engaged to Anna Jane. Monica had lunch with Henry on Valentine's Day of 1994, during which he allegedly said he wasn't seeing anyone.
实际上，他与安娜·简的婚礼仅剩两个月了。确信亨利现在有进一步的动机希望他的未婚妻出局，警方对这对夫妇的财务状况展开了全面调查。在购买人寿保险时，标准程序规定申请人必须披露他们可能与其他提供商签订的任何其他保单。尽管安娜·简有五份保险单，但她并没有在任何提案中披露这一点。调查人员很快意识到这是因为安娜·简根本没有提交这些提案。
In reality, his wedding to Anna Jane was just two months away. Convinced that Henry now had further motive to want his fiance out of the picture, a full investigation was launched into the couple's finances. When taking out life insurance, standard procedure dictates that an applicant must disclose any other policies they might have with other providers. Despite Anna Jane having five insurance policies, she hadn't disclosed this on any of her proposals. Investigators soon realized this was because Anna Jane hadn't submitted the proposals at all.
每份提案都是由亨利·基奥提交的，并伪造了安娜·简的签名。这对夫妇有一个共同的支票账户。亨利还伪造了安娜·简的签名来支付保费，以及恢复她现有的养老金账户。在每一份保单上，亨利·基奥都被列为受益人。针对亨利·基奥的间接证据是确凿的，但在提出任何指控之前，调查人员需要更多的物理证据来证明安娜·简并非死于自然原因。
Each proposal had been submitted by Henry Keough, complete with a forging of Anna Jane's signature. The couple shared a joint checking account. Henry had also forged Anna Jane's signature to pay for the premiums, as well as to reinstate her pre-existing superannuation account. On each policy, Henry Keough was listed as the beneficiary. The circumstantial evidence against Henry Keough was damning, but before placing any charges, investigators needed more physical proof that Anna Jane hadn't died from natural
毒理学结果还需要一些时间。但是，如果安娜·简滑倒并昏迷在浴缸里，法医病理学家科林·曼诺克博士认为她的大脑应该显示出受伤或淤青的迹象。没有发现此类证据。曼诺克博士提交了他的最终尸检报告，结论是安娜·简·切尼溺水时一定是清醒的。淤青因人而异。
causes. The toxicology results would still take some time. But, if Anna Jane had slipped and fallen unconscious into the bath, forensic pathologist Dr. Colin Manock believed that her brain would have displayed signs of injury or bruising. No such evidence had been visible. Dr. Manock submitted his final autopsy report, concluding that Anna Jane Cheney must have been conscious when she drowned. Bruisers differ greatly from individual to individual.
有些人会立即出现淤青，而另一些人则需要几天甚至几周。因此，曼诺克博士无法确切说明安娜·简腿上的淤青是什么时候发生的。鉴于在尸检的几天里它们变得越来越深，他确信它们发生在溺水后的四个小时内。到5月7日星期六，这位年轻律师去世已经七周了。亨利·基奥正在一个郊区体育场观看他的一个女儿打篮球。突然，两名警察走近并将他逮捕，理由是他涉嫌谋杀安娜·简·切尼。
Some people show signs of bruising straight away, while others take days or even weeks. Therefore, Dr. Manock couldn't say exactly when the bruises on Anna Jane's legs had occurred. Given they'd become darker over the days she was being autopsyed, he was convinced they'd happened within four hours of the time that she drowned. By Saturday, May 7, seven weeks had passed since the young lawyer's death. Henry Keough was watching one of his daughters play basketball at a suburban stadium. Suddenly, two police officers approached and placed him under arrest on suspicion of murdering
在拘留期间，亨利被问及是否知道他未婚妻众多的保险单。他对这个问题的回答和对其他所有问题的回答一样。无可奉告。第二天，亨利被控谋杀并被拒绝保释。安娜·简尸检的毒理学结果在接下来的一个月内完成。在安娜·简去世时，她的血液酒精浓度约为0.08%。
Anna Jane Cheney. In custody, Henry was questioned as to whether he was aware of his fiance's numerous life insurance policies. His answer to that was the same as every other question. No comment. The following day, Henry was charged with murder and refused bail. The toxicology results from Anna Jane's autopsy were finalised in the following month. At the time of Anna Jane's death, her blood alcohol had registered at around 0.08%.
她的体内没有药物或非法药物。但曼诺克博士认为，安娜·简只是在浴缸里睡着了的可能性极小。当一个人的气道受到威胁时，生存机制会自动启动。他们通常会开始咳嗽和窒息，并被肾上腺素激增唤醒。曼诺克博士认为安娜·简的醉酒程度不足以抵消这些反射。亨利·基奥的审判于1995年2月开始，即安娜·简去世11个月后。检方的案件是亨利出于贪婪而有经济动机杀害他的未婚妻。
There had been no medication or illegal drugs in her system. But Dr Manok was therefore highly unlikely that Anna Jane had simply fallen asleep in the bath. When a person's airways are threatened, survival mechanisms kick in automatically. They will typically begin coughing and choking and be woken by a surge of adrenaline. Dr Manok didn't think Anna Jane was intoxicated enough to cancel these reflexes out. Henry Keough's trial commenced in February 1995, 11 months after Anna Jane's death. The prosecution's case was that Henry had been financially motivated to kill his fiance
她多份人寿保险的伪造证明了预谋。亨利与另外两名女性的秘密恋情证明他并不认真对待他所宣称的对安娜·简的爱，也没有打算娶她。随着婚礼临近，检方表示，继承安娜·简的遗产将使亨利能够在享受自由的同时，继续为他的前妻和孩子提供经济支持。检方表示，没有证据支持意外死亡、自杀或陌生人的干预。
purely out of greed. The falsification of her multiple life insurance policies served as proof of premeditation. The secret affairs Henry had with two other women proved he wasn't serious about his professed love for Anna Jane or his intention of marrying her. With their wedding looming, the prosecution said that inheriting Anna Jane's estate would enable Henry to provide the ongoing financial support to his ex-wife and children while enjoying his freedom. The prosecution said there was no evidence to support accidental death, suicide, or intervention
相反，所有的矛头都指向亨利·基奥的谋杀。从他母亲家回来后，发现安娜·简在浴缸里，这给了他发动袭击的绝佳机会。鉴于安娜·简爱并信任亨利，当他进入浴室并伸手去触碰她时，她不会多想。这就是为什么没有挣扎的迹象。检方澄清说，证明亨利究竟何时或如何杀害安娜·简并不是他们的职责，只需要证明他确实犯下了罪行。
from a stranger. Instead, all fingers pointed to murder by Henry Keough. Having returned home from visiting his mother, finding Anna Jane in the bath gave him the perfect opportunity to launch an attack. Given that Anna Jane loved and trusted Henry, she would have thought nothing of it when he entered the bathroom and reached out to touch her. Hence why there was no sign of a struggle. The prosecution clarified that it wasn't their role to prove exactly when or how Henry
他们承认针对亨利·基奥的证据大多是间接的，但当所有因素结合在一起时，毫无疑问他杀害了安娜·简·切尼。据亨利说，当他发现安娜·简时，她正坐在浴缸的排水塞一端。在证人席上，科林·曼诺克博士提出了他的观点，即如果有人抓住一个人的腿并将他们折叠向头部，坐在这种位置的人很容易被淹没。
had killed Anna Jane, only that he had indeed committed the crime. They acknowledged that the evidence against Henry Keough was mostly circumstantial, but when all the factors were combined, there was no room for doubt that he had killed Anna Jane Cheney. According to Henry, when he found Anna Jane, she had been sitting at the plug end of the tub. On the stand, Dr Colin Manock presented his view that a person sitting in this position could be easily immersed if someone grabbed their legs and folded them down towards their
浴缸的形状意味着这个人的肩膀会被推到浴缸底部，困住他们的手臂，使他们无法挣扎。浮力效应会使身体很容易被拉过水面，水突然涌入鼻子会导致迅速失去知觉。对于曼诺克博士来说，安娜·简腿上类似手印的淤青支持了这一理论。她头上的淤青也表明有人可能把她猛地按入水下，而缺乏脑损伤表明她在溺水时一定是清醒的。
head. The shape of the bath meant the person's shoulders would be pushed to the bottom of the tub, trapping their arms and rendering them unable to struggle. The flotation effect would make it easy for the body to be pulled through the water, with a sudden rush of water going up the nose to cause rapid unconsciousness. For Dr Manock, the hand-like bruising on Anna Jane's legs supported this theory. The bruise on her head also indicated it was possible that someone had hurled her down below the water, while the lack of brain injury indicated she must have been conscious when
曼诺克博士的证词得到了他的同事罗斯·詹姆斯博士的支持。然而，詹姆斯博士不同意一点。他解释说，脑震荡在尸检中不会显示出来，因此他无法确认安娜·简在没入水下时是否清醒。另一位病理学家为检方作证说，证据也是间接的，他不认为答案在于法医。鉴于安娜·简的血液酒精浓度，他认为她有可能滑倒并撞到浴缸周围的任何硬表面上。
she drowned. Dr Manock's testimony was supported by his colleague Dr Ross James. However, Dr James disagreed with one thing. He explained that concussions don't show up in an autopsy, therefore he couldn't confirm that Anna Jane had been conscious when she went under the water. Another pathologist testified for the prosecution that the evidence was also circumstantial, that he didn't think the answers lay in the forensics. Given Anna Jane's blood alcohol level, he believed it was possible she could have slipped
至于安娜·简被抓住脚踝拉入水下的理论，他说：“我认为一个人在思考是什么造成了那种淤青时，想象力是唯一的限制。”辩方提交说，安娜·简的死不过是一场悲剧性的意外，将其提升为谋杀将是“可怕的司法不公”。他们辩称，安娜·简身上的淤青可能是由多种原因在任何时间造成的。
and cracked her head on any number of the hard surfaces surrounding the tub. As for the theory that Anna Jane had been pulled under water by her ankles, he said, I think really one is limited only by one's imagination in thinking of what sort of thing might have created those sorts of bruises. The defense submitted that Anna Jane's death was nothing more than a tragic accident, and that elevating it to murder would be a quote, terrible miscarriage of justice. They argued that the bruises on Anna Jane's body could have been caused by any number of things and at any time.
并撞到了浴缸周围的任何坚硬表面上。至于安娜·简被拽住脚踝拖入水下的说法，他说，我认为在想象究竟是什么造成了那些淤青时，人们的想象力是唯一的限制。辩方提出，安娜·简的死亡不过是一场悲剧性的意外，将其上升为谋杀案是“严重的司法不公”。他们辩称，安娜·简身上的淤青可能是由任何事物在任何时间造成的。
Not only were forensic experts unable to conclusively exclude the possibility that Anna Jane had died as the result of an accident, their client also had a legitimate explanation for the life insurance policies. In a highly anticipated move, Henry Keough took the stand in his own defense. He explained that as a side hustle, he worked as an independent insurance agent. For every insurance policy he sold, he received a commission from the relevant insurance company. To keep his agency active, he had to continue putting business through. In preparation for his inevitable retrenchment from the failing state bank, Henry submitted
法医专家不仅无法断定安娜·简的死因是否为意外，他们的当事人对人寿保险单也有合理的解释。亨利·基奥（Henry Keough）做出了一个备受期待的举动：他亲自出庭为自己辩护。他解释说，作为副业，他是一名独立保险代理人。他每卖出一份保险单，都会从相关的保险公司获得佣金。为了保持代理资格有效，他必须持续开展业务。在为即将从那家经营不善的州立银行被裁员做准备时，亨利提交了
policies in both his and Anna Jane's name. Not only did this keep his agency active, but the commissions he earned were larger than the premiums, making it a win-win situation. Although it wasn't legal, this was common practice within the industry. Henry claimed that Anna Jane was fully aware of the scheme and agreed to go along with it, provided she didn't have to do the paperwork or undergo any medical testing. Henry said he never had any intention of claiming payouts on any of the policies. If that was the case, the prosecution questioned why he had withheld this information from
以他自己和安娜·简名义购买的保单。这不仅保持了他的代理资格，而且他赚取的佣金比保费还要多，这是一种双赢的局面。虽然这不合法，但这在业内是常见的做法。亨利声称安娜·简完全知晓这一计划，并同意配合，前提是她不必处理文书工作或接受任何体检。亨利说他从未打算对任何保单进行索赔。如果真是这样，检方质疑他为什么在警察最初询问安娜·简的财务状况时隐瞒了这些信息，以及为什么亨利告诉安娜·简的父亲他不知道她是否有保险。
the police when they first inquired about Anna Jane's financial affairs, and why had Henry told Anna Jane's father he didn't know if she had any insurance. Furthermore, if Anna Jane knew about the policies, why did she only ever tell her friends and family about the one for $400,000? Henry explained he'd still been in a state of shock and confusion at the time. The defence attempted to exclude testimony from Belinda Morris and Monica Coleman, the two women Henry was alleged to have had affairs with, on the grounds that it didn't provide any genuine insight into his relationship with Anna Jane.
此外，如果安娜·简知道这些保单，为什么她只告诉朋友和家人那份40万美元的保单？亨利解释说，当时他仍处于震惊和混乱的状态。辩方试图排除贝琳达·莫里斯（Belinda Morris）和莫妮卡·科尔曼（Monica Coleman）的证词，这两名女性据称与亨利有染，理由是这些证词并不能真正深入了解他与安娜·简的关系。
The judge disagreed, and both women took the stand to provide the court with details about their relationship with the accused. Henry fully admitted to his relationship with Monica, but explained that it had taken place during a period of 1992 where he and Anna Jane had been taking a break, although he also acknowledged that the two relationships did overlap for a period of time. As for the relationship with Belinda, Henry admitted the two had been friends, but he strongly denied that they'd ever been romantically or sexually involved. Knowing that Belinda had never had a serious boyfriend before, Henry believed she was confused
法官不同意，两名女性都出庭向法庭提供了关于她们与被告关系的细节。亨利完全承认了他与莫妮卡的恋情，但解释说这是发生在1992年他与安娜·简处于冷静期的一段时间内，尽管他也承认这两段关系确实有一段时间是重叠的。至于与贝琳达的关系，亨利承认两人是朋友，但他强烈否认他们曾有过任何浪漫或性关系。亨利知道贝琳达以前从未有过认真的男朋友，他认为她误解了
about the attention he gave her. He admitted to calling Belinda while he was in Hong Kong with Anna Jane, but explained this was purely business-related. In response to the prosecution's claim that the relationship between Belinda and Henry intensified while Anna Jane was busy planning for the wedding, the defense argued that Belinda had become obsessed with Henry and created a fantasy. In the last few years, Belinda had lodged 30 sexual harassment claims against 21 of her male co-workers as well as one female.
他对她的关心。他承认在与安娜·简在香港时给贝琳达打过电话，但解释说这纯粹是与工作有关。针对检方关于贝琳达和亨利之间的关系在安娜·简忙于筹备婚礼时加剧的说法，辩方辩称贝琳达对亨利产生了执念，并幻想出了一段关系。在过去几年里，贝琳达曾对21名男性同事和一名女性同事提出了30项性骚扰指控。
Due to the stress it caused, she was placed under psychiatric care and eventually given leave from the bank. The defense suggested that Belinda was just an infatuated woman with psychiatric issues who had misread a platonic friendship, a claim she strongly denied. In an attempt to prove that the two had never had sex, the defense asked Belinda whether Henry was circumcised. She said that he was. In a bizarre move, a photo of Henry's erect penis was submitted into evidence.
由于压力过大，她接受了精神治疗，并最终从银行请假。辩方认为，贝琳达只是一个有精神问题的痴情女子，误读了一段柏拉图式的友谊，这一说法遭到了她的强烈否认。为了证明两人从未发生过性关系，辩方询问贝琳达亨利是否割过包皮。她说他割过。在一个离奇的举动中，一张亨利勃起时的阴茎照片被作为证据提交。
The photo confirmed that he was, in fact, not circumcised. After all the evidence was presented, the judge reiterated to the jury that the highly circumstantial nature of this case meant they had to take extra care when reaching their verdict. It all came down to reasonable doubt. It wasn't enough for the jury to think that murder might have taken place or had probably taken place. They could only find Henry Keough guilty of murdering Anna Jane if they couldn't find
照片证实他实际上并没有割过包皮。在所有证据提交完毕后，法官向陪审团重申，本案高度的间接证据性质意味着他们在做出裁决时必须格外小心。这一切都归结为合理怀疑。陪审团仅仅认为谋杀可能发生或很可能发生是不够的。只有在无法找到
any other reasonable hypothesis as to how she died. Regarding the insurance policies, the judge told the jury, It is a matter for you to decide as to how much Anna knew about these policies and when. If you are satisfied beyond reasonable doubt that she did not appreciate the complete picture, you are entitled to ask why. If there is a reasonable possibility that she knew details such as how much her life was insured for, then the crown case on motive is significantly reduced. As for the testimonies from Belinda and Monica, the judge urged that this evidence must only
任何其他关于她如何死亡的合理假设时，他们才能判定亨利·基奥谋杀安娜·简有罪。关于保险单，法官告诉陪审团：“安娜对这些保单了解多少以及何时了解，由你们来决定。如果你们确信无疑地认为她并不了解全貌，你们有权询问原因。如果她知道诸如她的人寿保险金额等细节的可能性是合理的，那么控方关于动机的论点就会大大削弱。”至于贝琳达和莫妮卡的证词，法官敦促这些证据必须仅
be considered in connection to Henry's relationship with Anna Jane, rather than as a smear on his character. The jury retired to consider its verdict. Unable to reach a unanimous decision, they were sequestered overnight to reconvene the next morning. But by midday the next day, they remained completely deadlocked. There would be no verdict. The jury was hung.
与亨利和安娜·简的关系联系起来考虑，而不是作为对他品格的抹黑。陪审团退庭商议裁决。由于无法达成一致意见，他们被隔离过夜，第二天早上重新开庭。但到了第二天中午，他们仍然完全陷入僵局。没有达成裁决。陪审团陷入了悬案。
The case was ordered to be retried the following week. By this point, the story had been so widely reported on in the presumption of Henry Keough being found guilty that his lawyer argued the case should be thrown out entirely. In his view, there was very little chance of finding an unbiased jury. The judge rejected this, but attempted to rectify the issue by postponing the retrial. The second trial went ahead four months later, in August 1995. The evidence and witnesses were mostly the same, but the presentation was streamlined thanks to a joint agreement by both parties.
案件被命令在下周重审。此时，关于亨利·基奥被认定有罪的预设报道已经非常广泛，以至于他的律师辩称该案应该被完全驳回。在他看来，找到一个公正陪审团的机会微乎其微。法官驳回了这一请求，但试图通过推迟重审来纠正这个问题。第二次审判在四个月后的1995年8月进行。证据和证人大多相同，但由于双方达成了一致协议，审理过程得到了简化。
Dr Colin Manock had retired just days before the proceedings, but he returned to give evidence. This time, a bathtub similar to the one in Anna Jane's home was brought into the court. Dr Manock knelt beside it and gave a physical demonstration of his theory as to how Anna Jane could have been gripped by the leg and held underwater. He said that all bruises on her body had been caused close to the time of death. Once again, Dr Ross James supported his colleague's theory. A new professor of forensic pathology was called as an expert witness for the defense. Given that the age of the bruises on Anna Jane's legs couldn't be conclusively ascertained,
科林·马诺克（Colin Manock）博士在庭审前几天刚刚退休，但他回来作证。这一次，一个类似于安娜·简家中的浴缸被带到了法庭。马诺克博士跪在浴缸旁，对他的理论进行了实物演示，即安娜·简是如何被抓住腿并按在水下的。他说她身上所有的淤青都是在死亡时间附近造成的。罗斯·詹姆斯（Ross James）博士再次支持了他同事的理论。一位新的法医病理学教授被传唤作为辩方的专家证人。鉴于安娜·简腿上淤青的年龄无法最终确定，
he had trouble accepting they were caused by a hand grip. The professor said he couldn't exclude the possibility that Anna Jane had died as the result of an accident, including a slip and fall that rendered her unconscious. In summing up the evidence, the judge reminded the jury, You cannot return a verdict of guilty unless the circumstances are such as to be inconsistent with any reasonable hypothesis other than that the accused is guilty. This time, it took the jury just five and a half hours to reach a unanimous verdict. Guilty.
他很难接受它们是由手抓造成的。这位教授说，他不能排除安娜·简死于意外的可能性，包括滑倒导致她失去知觉。在总结证据时，法官提醒陪审团：“除非情况与被告有罪之外的任何合理假设不符，否则你们不能做出有罪判决。”这一次，陪审团仅用了五个半小时就达成了全体一致的裁决。有罪。
Sentencing took place the following year in February. Anna Jane's parents were fiercely private during both trials and had not attended at any point except to give evidence. They provided a confidential victim impact statement to the judge, who said it was impossible to describe the suffering that the Cheney family had experienced. The judge said that while Anna Jane might have had some knowledge of the insurance policies, she had no idea of their extent. Henry's failure to disclose these policies at the start of the investigation was proof
判决于次年2月进行。安娜·简的父母在两次审判期间都非常低调，除了提供证词外，从未出席过任何庭审。他们向法官提交了一份保密的受害者影响陈述，法官称无法描述切尼（Cheney）一家所经历的痛苦。法官说，虽然安娜·简可能对保险单有一些了解，但她根本不知道其规模。亨利在调查开始时未能披露这些保单就是证明
of this. The judge concluded, When the facts are considered in this light, they reveal an elaborate and coldly planned scheme to kill Miss Cheney and profit from her death at a time when she was deeply in love with you and excitedly preparing to marry you. Henry sentenced Henry Keough to 25 years in prison, one of the highest sentences handed down in South Australia. Henry's lawyers immediately filed for an appeal.
这一点。法官总结道：“当从这个角度审视事实时，它们揭示了一个精心策划、冷酷无情的计划，旨在杀害切尼小姐，并在她深爱着你、兴奋地准备嫁给你的时候，从她的死亡中获利。”亨利判处亨利·基奥25年监禁，这是南澳大利亚州判处的最重刑罚之一。亨利的律师立即提起上诉。
Since the early stages of the investigation, the case had been reported on extensively with the media calling Anna Jane's death a murder and referring to her as a victim without using cautionary words like alleged. Articles had also gone to print in anticipation of a guilty verdict being handed down and therefore contained considerable comment about Henry in that vein. Given that this broke the journalistic rules about reporting fairly and accurately without comment, Henry's lawyers argued there had been unfair, prejudicial coverage of the trial. They also stated that the evidence provided by Belinda Morris and Monica Coleman should
自调查初期以来，该案就受到了广泛报道，媒体称安娜·简的死亡为谋杀，并称她为受害者，而没有使用“涉嫌”等谨慎用语。文章也在预判有罪判决的情况下付印，因此包含了大量关于亨利的此类评论。鉴于这违反了公平、准确、不带评论报道的新闻准则，亨利的律师辩称审判受到了不公平、带有偏见的报道。他们还指出，贝琳达·莫里斯和莫妮卡·科尔曼提供的证据应该
have been inadmissible. The appeal was swiftly rejected. From prison, Henry Keough maintained his innocence. He focused on fitness and read books to keep his mind busy, recognising the challenges faced by his fellow inmates helped prevent him from falling into a trap of self-pity. Visits from his daughters sustained him, but these became less frequent as Henry was transferred between different regional prisons. Henry's 10-year-old daughter encouraged him to stay positive.
是不可采信的。上诉很快被驳回。在狱中，亨利·基奥坚称自己无罪。他专注于健身并阅读书籍来充实自己的头脑，认识到狱友们面临的挑战有助于防止他陷入自怜的陷阱。女儿们的探视支撑着他，但随着亨利在不同地区监狱之间转移，探视变得不那么频繁了。亨利10岁的女儿鼓励他保持积极。
She wrote him a letter that said, I am trying to be brave just for you and I will hope for the best in the future. If you ever don't feel happy, do what I do. I think of you, so you think of me, and we will both be happy all of the time. In addition to the ongoing support of his family, Henry's case had attracted a growing number of supporters from the academic community as well as concerned citizens. They believed he had been served a severe miscarriage of justice and not just because the case relied so heavily on circumstantial evidence.
她给他写了一封信，说：“我正在努力为你变得勇敢，我会对未来抱有最好的希望。如果你感到不开心，就做我做的事。我想你，所以你也想我，我们都会一直开心的。”除了家人的持续支持，亨利的案件还吸引了学术界和关心此事的公民中越来越多的支持者。他们认为他遭受了严重的司法不公，不仅仅是因为该案过于依赖间接证据。
Firstly, there was the question of why Anna-Jane's body had been cremated before her death had even been officially registered. Secondly, Henry had been charged with murder before the toxicology results had even been confirmed. Thirdly, some were dubious whether the proposed murder scenario was even physically possible. But, at the heart of it all, lay a much bigger question. Between October 1992 and July 1993, three unrelated babies died under suspicious circumstances in Adelaide. They were presented to medics with various injuries, including skull fractures, bruises, wounds, and multiple broken bones.
首先，为什么安娜·简的尸体在她的死亡甚至还没有正式登记之前就被火化了？其次，亨利在毒理学结果甚至还没有确认之前就被指控谋杀。第三，有些人怀疑所提出的谋杀场景在物理上是否真的可能。但是，这一切的核心是一个更大的问题。1992年10月至1993年7月期间，阿德莱德有三名无关的婴儿在可疑情况下死亡。他们被送往医疗机构时带有各种伤痕，包括颅骨骨折、淤青、伤口和多处骨折。
Police officers, paramedics, and pediatricians attached to each case believed the infants showed glaring signs of severe abuse. They anticipated laying homicide charges against some of the parents. Autopsies were ordered, yet a pathologist determined that all three babies had died of an inflammation of the lungs called bronchonamonia. They were each recorded to have died by natural causes. Authorities were incredulous. The post-mortems were supposed to open lines of investigation, but had instead closed them.
负责每起案件的警官、护理人员和儿科医生认为，这些婴儿表现出严重的虐待迹象。他们预计会对一些父母提出杀人指控。尸检被下令进行，但一名病理学家断定这三名婴儿都死于一种称为支气管肺炎的肺部炎症。他们都被记录为死于自然原因。当局感到难以置信。尸检本应开启调查线索，却反而关闭了它们。
They requested that a coronial inquest be held to determine the true causes of death. Bolstering their belief that the diagnoses were grossly inadequate was the fact that the same pathologist had conducted each post-mortem. Dr. Colin Menoc The inquest revealed that Dr. Menoc had taken minimal tissue and organ samples to arrive at an accurate cause of death. His reports were noted as lacking detail. The coroner concluded that there was no evidence of bronchonamonia in two of the infants and
他们要求进行死因裁判官调查以确定真正的死因。支持他们认为诊断极其不准确这一信念的事实是，同一名病理学家进行了每一次尸检。科林·马诺克博士。调查显示，马诺克博士只提取了极少的组织和器官样本来得出准确的死因。他的报告被指出缺乏细节。验尸官得出结论，其中两名婴儿没有支气管肺炎的证据，
only minor traces in one. Even if science had been present, there was no forensic evidence to indicate such a condition would have caused to death. In one case, Dr. Menoc had interpreted a scar on one of the baby's bottoms to be nappy rash. It was presented that this could have actually been a cigarette burn. The injuries on another of the infants was described as being akin to those of an adult motor accident victim. The inquest into the baby's deaths also revealed that in the late 1970s, Dr. Menoc had taken
只有一名有轻微痕迹。即使存在这种疾病，也没有法医证据表明这种情况会导致死亡。在一个案例中，马诺克博士将婴儿臀部的一道疤痕解释为尿布疹。有人提出这实际上可能是烟头烫伤。另一名婴儿身上的伤痕被描述为类似于成年车祸受害者的伤痕。对婴儿死亡的调查还显示，在20世纪70年代末，马诺克博士曾
his employer to court after an attempt had been made to demote him from the position of director of forensic science. It was alleged that his co-workers had become increasingly concerned that Dr. Menoc lacked the specialist skills required to perform his job. While he had completed a medical degree in the United Kingdom, he had never completed the five years of histopathology study required of a senior pathologist. This entailed the microscopic examination of human cells and tissues for the presence of disease and was essential in certifying causes of death.
在试图将他从法医科学主任职位上降职后，将他的雇主告上法庭。据称，他的同事们越来越担心马诺克博士缺乏履行职责所需的专业技能。虽然他在英国获得了医学学位，但他从未完成高级病理学家所需的五年组织病理学研究。这涉及对人体细胞和组织进行显微镜检查以确定疾病的存在，对于证明死因至关重要。
In lieu of this qualification, Dr. Menoc simply completed a 20-minute oral exam. In court, Dr. Menoc's immediate superior admitted to knowing that Dr. Menoc wasn't adequately qualified for his role. He'd hired him due to lack of viable options. Regardless, Dr. Menoc won his industrial court case and his position was upheld. This meant it was his job to certify cause of death for such major clients as the State Police, Coroner's Office and the Director of Public Prosecutions, until his retirement almost 20 years later.
为了代替这一资格，马诺克博士只是完成了一次20分钟的口试。在法庭上，马诺克博士的直属上司承认知道马诺克博士的资格不足以胜任他的角色。他雇佣他是因为缺乏可行的选择。无论如何，马诺克博士赢得了他的劳资法庭案件，他的职位得到了保留。这意味着，直到他近20年后退休，他一直负责为州警察、验尸官办公室和公诉主任等主要客户证明死因。
The evidence regarding the three babies had been given several months before Henry Keough's murder trial, yet the findings weren't publicly disclosed until two days after Henry's conviction. This was a deliberate move by the coroner. He was concerned that publishing the results while the trial was underway would result in a mistrial. But for Henry Keough's supporters, it raised the question, if Dr. Menoc's findings in the three infant cases were found to be flawed, why was he able to testify as a major witness in the Anna Jane Cheney case at all?
关于这三名婴儿的证据在亨利·基奥谋杀案审判前几个月就已经给出，但调查结果直到亨利被定罪两天后才公开披露。这是验尸官的一个蓄意举动。他担心在审判进行期间公布结果会导致审判无效。但对于亨利·基奥的支持者来说，这提出了一个问题：如果马诺克博士在三起婴儿案件中的调查结果被发现是有缺陷的，为什么他还能作为安娜·简·切尼案的主要证人出庭作证？
Another Tony Thomas had been the pathologist tasked with reviewing Dr. Menoc's autopsies of the three babies as part of the coronial inquest. At the request of one of Henry Keough's supporters, he agreed to review Anna Jane Cheney's case. The fundamental duty of a pathologist is to consider all logical possibilities of a cause of death. However, at Henry's committal hearing, Dr. Menoc had blatantly stated, I was at no time looking or thinking that the death was accidental because I could find no explanation as to why she would drown.
另一位托尼·托马斯（Tony Thomas）是作为死因裁判官调查的一部分，负责审查马诺克博士对三名婴儿尸检的病理学家。在亨利·基奥的一名支持者的要求下，他同意审查安娜·简·切尼的案件。病理学家的基本职责是考虑死因的所有逻辑可能性。然而，在亨利的预审听证会上，马诺克博士公然声称：“我从未在任何时候寻找或认为死亡是意外，因为我找不到她为什么会溺水的解释。”
The prosecution had argued there was no other explanation for her death other than murder. But from Professor Thomas' experience, he didn't think it was all that unusual for an otherwise healthy young woman to die an unexplained death. Professor Thomas discovered that Dr. Menoc didn't request Anna Jane's medical records. He didn't send her heart or brain to be examined by specialists who could rule out whether Anna Jane had any defects that could help explain her sudden death. Nor did he take samples from her liver, pancreas or pelvis. The tissue samples he did take were declared woefully inadequate.
检方辩称，除了谋杀，她的死亡没有其他解释。但根据托马斯教授的经验，他不认为一个原本健康的年轻女性死于不明原因是一件多么不寻常的事情。托马斯教授发现，马诺克博士没有索取安娜·简的医疗记录。他没有将她的心脏或大脑送去给专家检查，以排除安娜·简是否有任何有助于解释她猝死的缺陷。他也没有从她的肝脏、胰腺或骨盆中提取样本。他提取的组织样本被宣布极其不足。
He'd submitted just one sample of heart tissue, whereas a specialist would have expected around 350 tissues from the heart alone. Weighing and measuring the body and organs of a deceased is considered standard practice during an autopsy. Dr. Menoc hadn't reported any of these things. Pathologists are required to document in writing all of their observations and findings, which must then be checked and initialed by an independent observer. Dr. Menoc didn't do this.
他只提交了一份心脏组织样本，而专家预计仅从心脏就应该提取约350份组织。在尸检过程中，对死者的身体和器官进行称重和测量被认为是标准做法。马诺克博士没有报告任何这些事情。病理学家必须书面记录他们所有的观察结果和发现，然后必须由独立观察员检查并签字。马诺克博士没有这样做。
It was also standard practice that colour photographs be taken during an autopsy showing the procedure, as well as the deceased's full body and full face. Neither Dr. Menoc nor any other forensic investigator had done this. The only photos that existed from the autopsy were 22 black and white images of Anna Jane's legs and torso. The most damning forensic evidence in Anna Jane Cheney's case were the subtle bruises on her left leg that purportedly supported the grip theory. When a bruise is microscopically examined, red blood cells can be seen in the surrounding
在尸检过程中拍摄显示程序以及死者全身和全脸的彩色照片也是标准做法。马诺克博士或任何其他法医调查员都没有这样做。尸检中仅存的照片是22张安娜·简腿部和躯干的黑白图像。安娜·简·切尼案中最具破坏性的法医证据是她左腿上细微的淤青，据称这些淤青支持了“抓握理论”。当淤青在显微镜下检查时，可以在周围看到红细胞
tissue. At Henry Keough's trial, Dr. Menoc had testified to confirming the existence of the bruise under microscope. Professor Thomas obtained the tissue samples from the crucial bruise on the inside of Anna Jane's leg that was said to have been caused by a thumbprint. He placed the slide under the microscope. He saw nothing. There was no scientific evidence that this was a bruise at all.
组织。在亨利·基奥的审判中，马诺克博士作证证实了显微镜下淤青的存在。托马斯教授获得了安娜·简腿内侧关键淤青的组织样本，据称该淤青是由指纹造成的。他将载玻片放在显微镜下。他什么也没看到。根本没有科学证据表明这是一个淤青。
And if there was no bruise, there was no evidence of the grip that allegedly proved Henry Keough had murdered Anna Jane Cheney. Dr. Robert Moles is a legal academic and researcher who in the 1990s worked for the Flinders University miscarriages of justice project. Five years after Henry Keough's murder conviction, he started looking into the case. With help from other supporters, Dr. Moles noticed that in addition to Professor Thomas' findings, there were several aspects that raised some serious red flags. To bolster the so-called grip theory at Henry's second trial, the prosecution introduced a
如果没有淤青，就没有证据表明存在所谓的抓握，从而证明亨利·基奥谋杀了安娜·简·切尼。罗伯特·莫尔斯（Robert Moles）博士是一位法律学者和研究员，他在20世纪90年代为弗林德斯大学的司法不公项目工作。在亨利·基奥被判谋杀罪五年后，他开始调查此案。在其他支持者的帮助下，莫尔斯博士注意到，除了托马斯教授的发现外，还有几个方面引起了严重的警示。为了在亨利的第二次审判中加强所谓的“抓握理论”，检方引入了一张
photograph of the inner side of Anna Jane's left leg. To the naked eye, the so-called thumb bruise was virtually non-existent. At the judge's request, Dr. Manok had circled it with a red marker. The problem with this was that he essentially directed the jury to see what Dr. Manok believed he'd seen. Tissue samples weren't available for the other marks that were thought to be bruises on Anna Jane's leg. If they were in fact bruises, there was no evidence that she had them before she got
安娜·简左腿内侧的照片。肉眼看来，所谓的拇指淤青几乎不存在。应法官的要求，马诺克博士用红色记号笔圈出了它。这样做的问题在于，他本质上是指示陪审团看到马诺克博士认为他所看到的东西。安娜·简腿上被认为是淤青的其他痕迹没有组织样本。如果它们确实是淤青，也没有证据表明她在进入浴缸之前就有这些痕迹。
into the bath. But the opposite was also true. As nobody had seen Anna Jane's legs that day, no one could say that she didn't already have them. In both trials, Dr. Manok testified that Anna Jane's aorta showed evidence of burst blood cells, in what's known as hemolytic staining. He called this a classic sign of freshwater drowning, a conclusion he'd reached by referring to a pathologist's handbook issued in 1968.
但反之亦然。由于那天没有人看到安娜·简的腿，没有人能说她之前没有这些痕迹。在两次审判中，马诺克博士都作证说，安娜·简的主动脉显示出溶血性染色的爆裂血细胞证据。他称这是淡水溺水的典型迹象，这一结论是他参考了1968年发布的一本病理学家手册得出的。
However, in more recent editions of this handbook, such reference had since been removed after it was determined that hemolytic staining could be caused by other processes, including natural decomposition. Therefore, it couldn't necessarily be attributed to what Dr. Manok had testified was a classic sign of freshwater drowning. Henry's supporters looked into some other murder cases where Dr. Manok provided evidence and noted several other instances of flawed or questionable practices. In one case, he'd performed an autopsy on an indigenous male outdoors on the street in
然而，在该手册的更新版本中，这种参考已被删除，因为人们确定溶血性染色可能是由其他过程引起的，包括自然分解。因此，它不一定能归因于马诺克博士所作证的淡水溺水的典型迹象。亨利的支持者调查了马诺克博士提供证据的其他一些谋杀案，并注意到了其他几个有缺陷或可疑做法的例子。在一个案例中，他在户外街道上对一名原住民男性进行了尸检，
full view of the public, much to the horror of onlookers. A professor of anatomy at the University of Adelaide dispelled Dr. Manok's drowning theory entirely, saying his views were inconsistent with the disciplines of anatomy and biomechanics. Dr. Manok had described the proposed drowning scenario as relatively easy. However, the anatomy professor said that the power of the extensor muscles in Anna Jane's legs would have been greater than the power that Henry Keough could exert through grabbing onto her calves. In 2001, a team of Henry's supporters gained permission from the new owners of Anna Jane's
在公众的注视下，令围观者感到恐惧。阿德莱德大学的一位解剖学教授完全驳斥了马诺克博士的溺水理论，称他的观点与解剖学和生物力学学科不一致。马诺克博士将所提出的溺水场景描述为“相对容易”。然而，这位解剖学教授表示，安娜·简腿部伸肌的力量将大于亨利·基奥通过抓住她小腿所能施加的力量。2001年，亨利的一支支持者团队获得了安娜·简家新主人的许可，
house to conduct a re-enactment of the murder scenario proposed by Dr. Colin Manok. They hired a model with similar proportions to Anna Jane, and using a male of similar proportions to Henry, they attempted all possible combinations of hand grips and positioning. In every case, the model was able to fight back to prevent her head from being held underwater. Sitting at the plug end, it wasn't even possible to pull her legs up fully overhead. A wall at the end of the bath prevented the acting perpetrator from gripping the model's legs in the manner Dr. Manok had described. Even if her head had gone underwater, her arms would have been free to grab the taps or edges
对科林·马诺克博士提出的谋杀场景进行了重演。他们雇佣了一名与安娜·简比例相似的模特，并使用一名与亨利比例相似的男性，尝试了所有可能的手抓和定位组合。在每种情况下，模特都能反击以防止她的头部被按在水下。坐在排水口一端，甚至不可能将她的腿完全拉到头顶上方。浴缸尽头的墙壁阻止了行凶者以马诺克博士描述的方式抓住模特的腿。即使她的头被按入水下，她的手臂也可以自由地抓住水龙头或浴缸边缘
of the tub or fight against her attacker, leaving visible injuries on both of them. Photographs of the re-enactment and statements discrediting Dr. Manok's theories were published in the Sunday Mail newspaper, leading to public outrage. The Cheney family complained to the press council, and Dr. Manok sued the paper for defamation. By this point, Henry Kao's supporters were stalwart. Their mission wasn't to prove that Henry was innocent, but that he'd received an unfair trial that had resulted in a miscarriage of justice. Undeterred by any criticism, investigative journalist Graham Archer joined the crusade
或与袭击者搏斗，在他们两人身上留下可见的伤痕。重演的照片和反驳马诺克博士理论的声明发表在《星期日邮报》上，引发了公众的愤怒。切尼一家向新闻委员会投诉，马诺克博士起诉该报诽谤。此时，亨利·基奥的支持者们立场坚定。他们的使命不是证明亨利是无辜的，而是证明他接受了一场导致司法不公的不公平审判。调查记者格雷厄姆·阿彻（Graham Archer）不顾任何批评，加入了这场运动，
and started covering the story extensively for Channel 7's current affairs show, Today Tonight. He would later report his detailed findings in a comprehensive award-winning book titled, Unmaking a Murder. Other major publications and TV shows started exposing the allegations against Dr. Manok, putting ongoing pressure on South Australian politicians to act. A specially established medical board agreed to review Dr. Manok's autopsy findings of the Anagene Cheney case, independent of any other complaints against the pathologist. Appearing before the board, Dr. Manok conceded that the tissue samples of the so-called bruise on Anagene's leg had improved, it was in fact a bruise. He admitted to being aware that hemolytic
并开始为第七频道的时事节目《今日今晚》（Today Tonight）广泛报道这个故事。他后来在一本名为《推翻谋杀》（Unmaking a Murder）的综合性获奖书籍中报告了他的详细发现。其他主要出版物和电视节目开始揭露针对马诺克博士的指控，给南澳大利亚州政客施加了持续的行动压力。一个专门成立的医疗委员会同意审查马诺克博士在安娜·简·切尼案中的尸检结果，独立于针对该病理学家的任何其他投诉。在委员会面前，马诺克博士承认安娜·简腿上所谓淤青的组织样本已经改善，它确实是一个淤青。他承认知道溶血性
staining was no longer a medically recognized sign of freshwater drowning, but stood by his diagnosis regardless. All four panellists unanimously found that Dr. Manok's autopsy had been incompetent, yet they concluded there was no unprofessional conduct on Dr. Manok's behalf. At Henry K.O.'s trial, Dr. Manok's colleague Dr. Ross James had also given testimony in support of Manok's findings. His evidence had been completely reliant on Manok's post-mortem report. At no point had Dr. James examined Anagene's body himself. Regardless, he'd supported his colleague's theory entirely, agreeing that the bruise on Anagene's left leg was caused by fingers. At the tribunal hearing, Dr. James admitted that he'd examined the tissue samples taken from
染色不再是医学上公认的淡水溺水迹象，但无论如何都坚持他的诊断。所有四名小组成员一致认为马诺克博士的尸检是不称职的，但他们得出结论，马诺克博士没有不专业的行为。在亨利·基奥的审判中，马诺克博士的同事罗斯·詹姆斯博士也作证支持马诺克的研究结果。他的证据完全依赖于马诺克的尸检报告。詹姆斯博士从未亲自检查过安娜·简的尸体。无论如何，他完全支持他同事的理论，同意安娜·简左腿上的淤青是由手指造成的。在法庭听证会上，詹姆斯博士承认他检查了从
Anagene's leg and found no evidence to indicate that there was a bruise. When asked why he didn't explain that to the jury, Dr. James responded, I didn't think it was particularly relevant. The medical board ultimately found that Dr. James was guilty of unprofessional conduct by failing to disclose relevant information to the court. In 2011, the case was featured in an episode of Australia's leading current affairs program 60 Minutes. It wasn't the first time a high-profile television show had questioned Henry K.O.'s guilt, but it was the first time that Dr. Colin Manok made an appearance. Speaking about the case of the three dead babies, Dr. Manok admitted that he'd gotten one of the slides mixed up.
安娜·简腿上提取的组织样本，没有发现任何迹象表明有淤青。当被问及为什么不向陪审团解释这一点时，詹姆斯博士回答说：“我不认为这特别相关。”医疗委员会最终认定詹姆斯博士因未向法庭披露相关信息而犯有不专业行为。2011年，该案在澳大利亚领先的时事节目《60分钟》的一集中播出。这不是高调电视节目第一次质疑亨利·基奥的有罪，但这是科林·马诺克博士第一次露面。谈到三名婴儿死亡的案件时，马诺克博士承认他把其中一张载玻片弄混了。
Presenter Carl Stefanovic called it a gross error. Manok responded casually, it is an unfortunate error, but one which can be made when things are hectic. Dr. Manok conceded that the supposed bruises on Anagene's legs could have been up to four days old. Stefanovic asked Manok what evidence there was that Henry K.O. had killed his fiance. Manok responded, the evidence is the cause of death was drowning. A bewildered Stefanovic said, that's drowning, that's not murder. To which Dr. Manok replied, that's right, the evidence is there was large amounts of life insurance on her. Stefanovic pointed out, that's motive, it's only motive if there's been a murder.
主持人卡尔·斯特凡诺维奇（Carl Stefanovic）称这是一个严重的错误。马诺克随意地回答说：“这是一个不幸的错误，但在事情繁忙时可能会发生。”马诺克博士承认安娜·简腿上所谓的淤青可能长达四天。斯特凡诺维奇问马诺克有什么证据表明亨利·基奥杀害了他的未婚妻。马诺克回答说：“证据是死因是溺水。”困惑的斯特凡诺维奇说：“那是溺水，不是谋杀。”对此，马诺克博士回答说：“没错，证据是她身上有大量的人寿保险。”斯特凡诺维奇指出：“那是动机，只有在发生谋杀时才是动机。”
Stefanovic said it would take a brave attorney to reopen Henry K.O.'s case, given that testimony from Dr. Manok had been given in over 400 South Australian convictions. He said lifting the lid on Dr. Manok's forensic career could open a Pandora's box. Stefanovic asked Dr. Manok if he was worried that a review of Henry K.O.'s case would lead to all of his cases being reviewed. Laughing, Dr. Manok answered, I really don't know. I'm too old to worry like that. In South Australia, a convicted criminal can only lodge one application to the court of appeal. Once Henry's appeal was rejected, his best bet was to file a petition for
斯特凡诺维奇说，鉴于马诺克博士的证词已在400多起南澳大利亚州的定罪中使用，需要一位勇敢的律师才能重开亨利·基奥的案件。他说，揭开马诺克博士的法医职业生涯可能会打开潘多拉的盒子。斯特凡诺维奇问马诺克博士是否担心对亨利·基奥案件的审查会导致他所有的案件都被审查。马诺克博士笑着回答说：“我真的不知道。我太老了，不会担心那种事。”在南澳大利亚州，被定罪的罪犯只能向法院提出一次上诉申请。一旦亨利的上诉被驳回，他最好的选择是提交一份请愿书
mercy to the Governor of South Australia. If successful, his case could then be referred back to the appeal court. Over the years, Henry's legal team lodged three petitions outlining the flawed evidence in Dr. Manok's autopsy and subsequent testimony. Each plea was rejected. The Solicitor General admitted there were minor issues with the forensic details, but concluded that this didn't cancel out the fact that Henry K.O. had forged Anna Jane Cheney's signature on over $1 million of life insurance, of which he was the sole beneficiary. After the third rejection, a spokesperson said,
请求南澳大利亚州总督宽大处理。如果成功，他的案件随后可以被移交回上诉法院。多年来，亨利的法律团队提交了三份请愿书，概述了马诺克博士尸检和随后的证词中存在的缺陷证据。每一次请求都被驳回。总检察长承认法医细节存在细微问题，但得出结论认为，这并不能抵消亨利·基奥在超过100万美元的人寿保险上伪造了安娜·简·切尼签名，且他是唯一受益人的事实。在第三次被驳回后，一位发言人说：
The people of South Australia can be comforted in the knowledge that a two-and-a-half-year exhaustive examination has concluded that there is no doubt as to the guilt of Henry K.O. Henry's legal team eventually submitted a fourth petition against Henry's conviction. It was a monumental undertaking, with four books worth of information making it the most dense submission yet. The submission argued that Henry's case be revisited on the fact that, quote, The prosecution as it was presented at trial no longer exists. Every feature of that case has either been withdrawn, in some instances totally altered, and in other instances, completely demolished.
“南澳大利亚州人民可以感到欣慰的是，一项为期两年半的详尽审查已经得出结论，亨利·基奥的有罪是毫无疑问的。”亨利的法律团队最终提交了第四份针对亨利定罪的请愿书。这是一项巨大的工程，四本书的信息量使其成为迄今为止最密集的提交材料。该提交材料主张基于以下事实重新审视亨利的案件，引用：“审判时提出的控方论点已不复存在。该案件的每一个特征要么已被撤回，在某些情况下完全改变，在另一些情况下，被彻底推翻。”
In 2013, new laws were passed in South Australia that allowed for prisoners to appeal again if they had fresh and compelling evidence. Henry appointed a new legal team, who managed to uncover a report that had been sitting on the government shelves for nine years. When Henry K.O. had submitted his third petition for mercy in 2004, the Solicitor General ordered a government-appointed forensic expert to conduct an independent review. The job went to Professor Barry Vernon Roberts. In his 16-page report, he concluded there was no pathology to support the hypothesis that Anna Jane Cheney had drowned as a result of someone gripping her lower legs to force her
2013年，南澳大利亚州通过了新法律，允许囚犯在有新的和令人信服的证据时再次上诉。亨利聘请了一个新的法律团队，他们设法发现了一份在政府书架上存放了九年的报告。当亨利·基奥在2004年提交他的第三份宽大处理请愿书时，总检察长下令一名政府任命的法医专家进行独立审查。这项工作交给了巴里·弗农·罗伯茨（Barry Vernon Roberts）教授。在他16页的报告中，他得出结论，没有病理学证据支持安娜·简·切尼因有人抓住她的小腿强迫她
under water. Vernon Roberts believed that Henry's case had been removed from the court and that Anna Jane had more likely passed out from some kind of cardiac episode, knocked her head on the bathtub, and then drowned while unconscious. He found no evidence of foul play. Despite the government having this information from their own expert witness, they had concluded that no miscarriage of justice had been served against Henry K.O. With this report and all the other information that had come to light since his conviction, Henry K.O. lodged an application to appeal. This time, his request was granted.
进入水下而溺水的假设。弗农·罗伯茨认为亨利的案件已被移出法庭，安娜·简更有可能是因为某种心脏发作而昏倒，头部撞在浴缸上，然后在失去知觉时溺水身亡。他没有发现任何不法行为的证据。尽管政府从他们自己的专家证人那里获得了这些信息，但他们仍得出结论，认为亨利·基奥没有受到司法不公。有了这份报告和自他定罪以来曝光的所有其他信息，亨利·基奥提交了上诉申请。这一次，他的请求得到了批准。
The appeal hearing went ahead in December 2014, during which all the new evidence was presented. It was also put forward that swelling on Anna Jane's face at the time of her death could have indicated an allergic reaction caused by an antihistamine she'd been prescribed in the past. One forensic expert said it was possible that the bruises on Anna Jane's head could have actually been caused during the autopsy. The court of appeal ultimately found that Dr. Manok's evidence was flawed and the verdict was therefore unsafe. The judgment said, There is nothing in the autopsy findings to exclude the probability that Ms. Cheney's death was a drowning in the bath following a fall and a head injury which
上诉听证会在2014年12月进行，期间提交了所有新证据。还提出，安娜·简在死亡时脸部的肿胀可能表明她过去曾被开过抗组胺药引起的过敏反应。一位法医专家表示，安娜·简头部的淤青可能实际上是在尸检过程中造成的。上诉法院最终认定马诺克博士的证据是有缺陷的，因此判决是不安全的。判决书称：“尸检结果中没有任何内容可以排除切尼小姐在跌倒和头部受伤后在浴缸中溺水的可能性，这导致她
rendered her unconscious. A number of highly significant observations and opinions of Dr. Manok materially misled the prosecution, the defense, the trial judge, and the jury. In these circumstances, there has been a substantial miscarriage of justice. Henry K.O.'s conviction was overturned and he was released on bail after two decades behind bars. However, this wasn't an acquittal. He would still have to face trial for a third time. Henry left the courthouse with his now adult daughters by his side. Applauses arose from the crowd of his supporters who gathered outside. Henry K.O.'s third trial was scheduled for March 2016, this time before a judge alone.
失去了知觉。马诺克博士的一些非常重要的观察和意见在实质上误导了控方、辩方、审判法官和陪审团。在这种情况下，存在严重的司法不公。”亨利·基奥的定罪被推翻，他在入狱二十年后获准保释。然而，这并不是无罪释放。他仍然必须面临第三次审判。亨利在现在已成年的女儿们的陪同下离开了法院。聚集在外面的支持者人群中响起了掌声。亨利·基奥的第三次审判定于2016年3月进行，这次由法官单独审理。
As the director of public prosecutions began preparing for the retrial, it emerged that a key witness had become ill and wouldn't be available to give evidence. Without their testimony and cross-examination, the DPP concluded that it wasn't appropriate to proceed. The witness was none other than Dr. Colin Manok. On November 13, 2015, the DPP held a hearing to formally declare a nolly prosecwee, meaning the murder charge against Henry K.O. was being dropped. Henry wasn't present for the hearing, but outside court his brother told reporters,
当公诉主任开始准备重审时，出现了一名关键证人患病且无法提供证据的情况。由于没有他们的证词和交叉询问，公诉主任得出结论，继续进行是不合适的。这名证人正是科林·马诺克博士。2015年11月13日，公诉主任举行了一次听证会，正式宣布“不予起诉”（nolle prosequi），这意味着针对亨利·基奥的谋杀指控被撤销。亨利没有出席听证会，但在法庭外，他的兄弟告诉记者：
Today my brother walks effectively free after 21 years in prison. 21 years an innocent man for a crime he didn't do. For a crime that sadly never occurred. Henry will be taking some time to restructure his life and try to recapture those 21 years that he's lost. A lawyer read a statement on Henry's behalf that said, I now look forward to trying to make up for all those lost years with my family and friends. I want to state very clearly that I loved my fiancee Anna Jane and absolutely deny having anything to do with her death. This was and still is a terrible tragedy for Anna Jane,
“今天，我的兄弟在入狱21年后实际上获得了自由。21年，一个无辜的人因为他没有犯下的罪行而入狱。因为一个可悲的是从未发生的罪行。亨利将花一些时间来重组他的生活，并试图夺回他失去的那21年。”一位律师代表亨利宣读了一份声明，称：“我现在期待着努力与我的家人和朋友弥补所有那些失去的岁月。我想非常清楚地声明，我爱我的未婚妻安娜·简，并绝对否认与她的死亡有任何关系。这对安娜·简来说，过去是，现在仍然是一个可怕的悲剧。”
her family and me. The Cheney family weren't present for the hearing and they requested the media respect to their privacy. Later speaking to channel seven, Henry K.O. said he was making no immediate plans for the future given that he'd been disappointed by the legal system too many times already. He remained a person of interest in Anna Jane Cheney's death and could still be charged at any time. Henry said the fact that the retrial wouldn't be going ahead was good enough for him stating, I have my liberty, I know the truth, those that love me and support me know the truth and that's enough. To avoid having to face any civil action, the state government awarded Henry K.O. an ex-Gracia payment of two and a half million dollars. While being significantly
他的家人和我。切尼一家没有出席听证会，他们要求媒体尊重他们的隐私。后来在接受第七频道采访时，亨利·基奥表示，鉴于他已经多次对法律体系感到失望，他目前没有对未来做任何计划。他仍然是安娜·简·切尼死亡案的嫌疑人，随时可能被起诉。亨利说，重审不会进行这一事实对他来说已经足够了，他表示：我获得了自由，我知道真相，那些爱我、支持我的人也知道真相，这就足够了。为了避免面对任何民事诉讼，州政府向亨利·基奥支付了250万澳元的特惠赔偿金。虽然这笔钱明显
less than the six million dollars Henry sought, he ultimately accepted the offer. The decision to compensate him caused a stir among politicians and the public who remained divided in their view of Henry K.O.'s innocence. The payout was disputed in a parliamentary inquiry during which lawyers for the Cheney family said, The family were shocked and appalled that this government saw fit to pay any money, let alone what they regard as an obscene sum to a man who they regard as the person that murdered their daughter and their sibling. Henry argued that the smaller figure wasn't enough to make up for everything that he lost, saying, More than 7000 sunrises and sunsets that I never saw. Can you sit here today and even contemplate the everyday joys and happiness that
少于亨利要求的600万澳元，但他最终还是接受了这一提议。给予他赔偿的决定在政界和公众中引起了轰动，他们对亨利·基奥是否无辜的看法仍然存在分歧。这笔赔偿金在议会调查中受到了质疑，切尼一家的律师在调查中表示：这家人感到震惊和愤慨，政府竟然认为支付任何赔偿是合适的，更不用说他们认为这是一笔给一个被他们视为谋杀女儿和姐妹的凶手的人的巨额款项。亨利辩称，较小的赔偿金额不足以弥补他失去的一切，他说：我错过了7000多个日出和日落。你今天能坐在这里，甚至去想象那些你认为理所当然的日常快乐和幸福吗？
you take for granted that I missed out on? The marriage of children, the birth of grandchildren, my own advancement in the workplace. I believe I'm owed a debt for this nightmare, as is my family, as is Anna Jane, who deserves better to be falsely remembered as the woman killed by the man she loved and the man who loved her. You've called this inquiry to ask why I was given an ex-grassia payment. I ask, why not? What price would you put on 20 years of your life if that had been stolen from you? In a Channel 7 interview in 2018, Henry said one of the true tragedies of the whole ordeal was that the autopsy was so flawed that the truth about how Anna Jane died will never be known. Speaking about his experience, he said, I've never considered myself
我错过了这些。子女的婚礼、孙辈的出生、我在职场上的晋升。我相信我应该为这场噩梦得到赔偿，我的家人也一样，安娜·简也一样，她不应该被错误地记住为一个被她所爱且爱她的男人杀害的女人。你们召开这次调查是为了询问为什么给我特惠赔偿金。我问，为什么不呢？如果20年的生命被偷走，你会给它标上什么价格？在2018年接受第七频道采访时，亨利说，整个磨难中真正的悲剧之一是尸检存在严重缺陷，以至于安娜·简死亡的真相永远无法得知。谈到他的经历时，他说：我从未认为自己
a victim and I didn't want to bang on about poor me. That just gets totally boring and doesn't serve anybody. Henry said he no longer placed importance on being acquitted. As long as he had his freedom and liberties, he didn't want to waste more of his time in court. One of his daughters said, It doesn't really matter to me if people think he's guilty or not. This isn't even about clearing his name. It's about the biggest story, about the system that needs to change. Henry Keough now spends his days making up for lost time with his daughters and grandchildren. He refuses to hold on to any bitterness or resentment. Alongside other rex inmates, Henry works for an organisation that provides support for individuals
是一个受害者，我不想喋喋不休地抱怨自己有多可怜。那只会让人感到厌烦，对任何人都没有帮助。亨利说，他不再把被判无罪看得那么重要。只要他拥有自由，他就不想在法庭上浪费更多时间。他的一个女儿说：人们认为他是否有罪对我来说并不重要。这甚至不是为了洗清他的名声。这是关于一个更大的故事，关于需要改变的体制。亨利·基奥现在每天都在弥补与女儿和孙辈们失去的时间。他拒绝怀有任何怨恨。除了其他获释的囚犯外，亨利还为一家组织工作，该组织为个人提供支持
once they're released from prison. Their aim is to break the cycle that sees so many inmates going in and out of jail. In 2020, Henry told the advertiser, I don't judge people. I didn't want to be judged and I certainly wasn't going to start pointing the finger at anybody. I firmly believe all of us are more than whatever has happened to us or the sum of the worst things we have done. Over the years, numerous requests have been made for an inquiry into the cases where Dr. Colin Manock's evidence helped secure a conviction. The likeliness of this going ahead seems minimal. Not only would this be a mammoth undertaking in terms of resources and costs, some believe that Henry Keough's large compensation payout is another deterrent. If an inquiry led to other
一旦他们出狱。他们的目标是打破许多囚犯反复进出监狱的恶性循环。2020年，亨利告诉《广告人报》：我不评判别人。我不想被评判，我也绝对不会开始指责任何人。我坚信我们每个人都不仅仅是发生在我们身上的事情或我们所做过的最坏事情的总和。多年来，人们多次要求对科林·马诺克博士的证据帮助定罪的案件进行调查。这进行的可能性似乎微乎其微。这不仅在资源和成本方面是一项艰巨的任务，一些人认为亨利·基奥的高额赔偿金是另一个威慑因素。如果调查导致其他
convictions being quashed, the government could be liable for millions of dollars in payouts. Dr. Robert Moles was one of Henry Keough's constant supporters. He runs a website dedicated to the case and other potential miscarriages of justice, called Networked Knowledge. Speaking of Anna Jane Cheney's death, Dr. Moles said, Maybe no one knows what really happened on that dreadful night. We can make an educated guess just as the jury was invited to do. When we make such a guess, we do so based on the information that we have at the time, combined with our more general views of human nature and society. Such judgments may be better or worse than others. But we can never really know what happened.
定罪被撤销，政府可能要承担数百万美元的赔偿。罗伯特·莫尔斯博士是亨利·基奥的坚定支持者之一。他经营着一个致力于该案件和其他潜在司法不公案件的网站，名为“网络知识”。谈到安娜·简·切尼的死亡，莫尔斯博士说：也许没有人知道那个可怕的夜晚到底发生了什么。我们可以像陪审团被邀请做的那样，做出有根据的猜测。当我们做出这样的猜测时，我们是基于当时掌握的信息，结合我们对人性和社会更普遍的看法。这样的判断可能比其他判断更好或更坏。但我们永远无法真正知道发生了什么。
The Cheney family are as fiercely private about the case today as they were in 1994. Despite the flawed forensics, they still believe there is enough circumstantial evidence against Henry Keough to warrant a retrial. The Cheneys were never consulted about the nolly prosecwee. A statement released by their lawyer in 2018 said a retrial was their only hope for closure. It's a case that continues to divide the public. Some call it one of the biggest miscarriages of justice Australia has ever seen, while others think a guilty man walks free.
切尼一家今天对案件的隐私保护和1994年一样严密。尽管法医鉴定存在缺陷，但他们仍然认为有足够的间接证据证明亨利·基奥有罪，足以进行重审。切尼一家从未被咨询过关于“不予起诉”的决定。他们的律师在2018年发表的一份声明中表示，重审是他们获得解脱的唯一希望。这是一个继续让公众产生分歧的案件。有些人称这是澳大利亚有史以来最大的司法不公之一，而另一些人则认为一个有罪的人逍遥法外。
A statement made by one of Anna Jane's friends in 1995 highlights an important point to remember as the debate continues. She said, I think it is fitting that Anna Jane be remembered for the beautiful person she was, not just as the body in the bath. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
安娜·简的一位朋友在1995年发表的一份声明强调了在辩论继续进行时需要记住的一个重要点。她说：我认为，安娜·简应该被铭记为她曾经那个美丽的人，而不仅仅是浴缸里的尸体，这是很恰当的。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。